The world may not agree on just how “real”
professional wrestling, or “sports entertainment”
may be, but when the masses love or hate one
performers above the rest, mainstream fame
is usually within reach.
Not every pro wrestler who has pursued a Hollywood
acting career has found success, but that
might not be as bad as it sounds.
Some of the greatest legends of wrestling
found their way into Hollywood films… and
still, nobody noticed.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Wrestlers You
Didn’t Know Appeared in Movies.
Hulk Hogan
Sure, Hulk Hogan made more appearances in
Hollywood films than nearly any other wrestler
before or since, but one of his strangest
roles unfortunately slipped by plenty of younger
moviegoers.
The original Gremlins is a classic, but its
sequel is a whole lot… weirder.
But director Joe Dante was offered the job
with the promise that he could do just about
anything he wanted with The New Batch.
As a result, audiences were stunned to see
the film burn up, apparently the work of the
film’s maniac monsters.
Luckily, Hulk Hogan was sitting in the same
theater, intimidating the Gremlins until they
returned to the regular programming.
The cameo was strange and unexpected, but
sadly, was replaced in the home video release,
depriving thousands of Hulkamaniacs from seeing
it for themselves.
Terry Funk
He may not have gained the mainstream fame
of Hulk Hogan or Randy Savage, but there aren’t
many Hall of Fame wrestlers who can hold a
candle to Terry Funk.
So it’s no surprise he took his signature
hardcore attitude onto the big screen, appearing
in movies like Road House and Over The Top.
It’s hard to believe that the towering beast
could ever be beaten in a fight by Patrick
Swayze or Sam Elliott, but since he’s as
famous for his love of a good time as he is
for his fighting, we’re willing to bet he
simply let the movie stars win.
Lenny Montana
Beginning his wrestling career as The Zebra
Kid, the Brooklyn-born Lenny Montana found
success due mainly to his 6-foot-6-inch frame.
But when wrestling dried up for Montana in
the late ‘60s, his size was put to another
use: recruited to work as an enforcer for
New York’s Columbo Crime Family.
After a stint in prison, Montana acted as
a bodyguard for the family, which is what
brought him onto the set of Francis Ford Coppola’s
Godfather.
The massive but softspoken enforcer was immediately
cast as Vito Corleone’s top hitman, Luca
Brasi.
Even with a small part in the movie, Montana
would enjoy a long acting career as a direct
result.
Captain Lou Albano
It’s one thing to turn wrestling success
into a career in Hollywood, but doing it without
most people noticing is something else.
No wrestling fan of ‘50s and ‘60s will
forget Captain Lou Albano, since he racked
up wins and legendary status as both a wrestler
and manager – and his long beard, face piercings,
and Hawaiian shirts didn’t hurt either.
Despite that fame, Lou Albano’s acting chops
made him almost unrecognizable as the slick
Sicilian Frank “The Fixer” in Brian De
Palma’s Wise Guys.
And even fewer fans realized the once-crazed
wrestler would entertain kids every week as
Nintendo’s mascot in The Super Mario Bros.
Super Show!
Now THAT’s range.
Kevin Nash
It’s hard to think of a pro wrestler who
has found more success than Kevin Nash.
Winning almost two dozen world championships
and founding the nWo, the man formerly known
as Diesel found legitimate fame in films and
TV, most recently appearing in the Magic Mike
films as “Tarzan.”
But Nash’s fans may have caught his big
screen debut earlier than they thought.
When the villain Shredder ingested the mutating
ooze in the second Ninja Turtles movie, it
was Nash who brought the gigantic “Super
Shredder” to life.
Let’s be glad that none of his other roles
required the actor to bury himself under a
dock for no reason whatsoever.
Sable
The 1990s were a serious turning point for
the WWF, as the Attitude Era saw the company
target new adult audiences – and their new
Divas more than did the trick.
No female wrestler was more popular than Rena
Mero, better known as Sable, and one of the
first female performers to show off her athleticism
along with good looks.
When Sable left the WWF in 1999, she turned
to films… but we doubt that beating up former
SNL cast member Chris Kattan in Corky Romano
was what she had in mind.
As satisfying as it was to watch her fight,
the flop must have opened her eyes.
She returned to wrestling shortly after.
Big John Studd
It takes a special kind of villain to bring
a stretcher to the ring so his opponent can
be carried out when the fight is over, but
Big John Studd lived up to his name, going
toe-to-toe with the massive Andre the Giant.
A monster heel that big would be hard to miss,
but there are some wrestling fans who never
saw one of his best roles: the bruiser Jack
Daniels in Harley Davidson and the Marlboro
Man.
The film was a bomb, but that doesn’t mean
it’s any less fun to watch Studd throw Mickey
Rourke out a window.
Since Rourke would play a pro wrestler twenty
years later, we like to think Studd taught
him a few tricks of the trade.
George ‘The Animal’ Steele
When Jim Myers started wrestling in his free
time, it was only meant to help him pay bills
when we wasn’t working as a high school
wrestling and football coach.
But when wrestling took off, Myers took the
name of ‘The Animal,’ and wrestled for
the next several decades.
In a strange twist of fate, Steele also landed
a role in Tim Burton’s biopic of the enigmatic
director Ed Wood.
Steele was recruited to play the part of Wood’s
friend and collaborator Tor Johnson – himself
a Swedish wrestler turned film actor.
Ox Baker
Although he began his wrestling career as
a nerdy hero, the legendary Ox Baker soon
became one of the most well-known villains
of the 1960s.
Famous for his heated interviews and his signature
move – The Heart Punch – it was only a
matter of time until Ox made it into film.
Escape From New York became a cult classic
thanks to director John Carpenter’s dystopic
Manhattan prison, and Ox was definitely in
top form when taking on Snake Plissken in
a fight to the death.
With a catchphrase as simple as “I love
to hurt people,” there’s no doubt that
he enjoyed the chance to do just that to star
Kurt Russell.
Kimberly Page
Diamond Dallas Page was one of the biggest
names to ever come out of the WCW, but his
wife and on-screen manager Kimberly was just
as memorable.
But wrestling fans would be forgiven if they
didn’t catch her surprise cameo in Judd
Apatow’s 40 Year Old Virgin.
Stepping into the spotlight thanks to a wardrobe
malfunction at a speed dating event may not
have been the return to fame she was hoping
for, but it definitely makes her brief appearance
hard to forget.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite memorable
performances from wrestlers-turned actors?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel and watch
more videos like this one.